où
qu'arrive-t-il à whisper direct que sa
terre la maserati l'intervalle liqueur
qu'est-ce qui a oui ce qu'on est
on voit ça quand je ferme les yeux
ça doit être le symbole de la région
d'origine du sport elle aussi une
nouvelle aventure l'attend
ou est ce que tu vas chicka wow ça fait
des années que je n'ai pas entendu
et ça fait une semaine qu'on t'attend
vraiment fait saunière pas vrai tu viens
pour le jazz est né
et toi tu es qui femmes pour cette
blague
tu prends ça ce que je pense
[Musique]
bien je vais présenter à la famille
oui
sonia est arrivé enfin la vraie sonia
alors j'ai tout question qui est sonia
et qui ose appeler ça une douche
fanny pedro a vendu la source quoi s'en
vont les secours ne pourront pas
survivre aura c'est l'avis de vendu à 6
à des étrangers ils m'ont promis de tout
conserver en l'état
tu pensais vraiment qu'on allait
s'occuper de ses chevaux des chevaux
sauvages en plus et on faisait renaître
la course mythique
on pourrait sauver aura la course 2
[Musique]
les gens disent que le cheval qui
gagnait la course doha devenait l'âme de
l'andalousie
[Applaudissements]